ça roule à nouveau pour le bibliobus ce
véhicule itinérant permet d'accéder à
une sélection de documents sans se
rendre en médiathèque et d'importants de
compléter et de relayer l'offre des
médiathèques en allant au plus près des
habitants 1 aux endroits où les
médiathèques sont un peu éloignés des
médiathèques ce qu on appelle les zones
blanches et puis vers les publics qui ne
peuvent pas se déplacer les personnes
peuvent également récupérer ou rendre
les documents commander sur le portail i
médiathèque ou emprunter un livre où il
faut être inscrit et la médiathèque ou
au bibliobus
pour ce faire il faut remplir un contrat
d'adhésion ça le contrat d'adhésion
permet d'emprunter tous supports louvre
pour quatre à six semaines et
vous pouvez venir au bus comme vous
pouvez venir dans n'importe quelle
médiathèques du réseau
vous pouvez également réserver sur le
portail des médiathèques
en indiquant
la tournée des bus et y'a pas de soucis
on est là ce véhicule neuf
habillé des dessins de l'auteur et
illustrateur philippe ugg continuera ses
arrêts pour le plus grand plaisir des
habitants de saint quentin en yvelines
pour délivrer et aussi des livres c'est
bien d'apporter la lecture on peut
avancer aller ça on est dans les écoles
ça venait devant les écoles et les
enfants aller faire un petit tour
donc plus on peut apporter la la
littérature l'allée du plaisir de lire
aux enfants
mieux c'est le bibliobus à d'autres
arrêts programmés il sera par exemple le
samedi à magny les hameaux t 10 heures
30 au centre social le buisson des
informations complémentaires sont à
retrouver sur le site de la médiathèque
de saint quentin en yvelines